y antonio
en un momento está centrado en la
atención con el 19
quiero lamentar primero cada muerte que
ha ocurrido
en mi país los problemas que ambos
deberían ser tratados simultáneamente
sin restricciones de movimiento
ejercicio de libertad fuera de lectura
verdad fuera delegadas a cada uno de los
20 de cooperadores de las unidades de la
federación el presidente como envío de
recursos y medios a todo el país como
aconteció en gran parte del mundo
parcela de
estamos en frente 24 transmitiendo para
ustedes la asamblea general de la onu en
su versión número 75 ha iniciado como es
costumbre brasil en cabeza del
presidente brasileño jair bolsonaro que
comenzó su intervención lamentando los
fallecimientos y explicando que ha
estado en poder de los gobernadores el
manejo de la pandemia con medidas que
han incluido el distanciamiento social
como ha sucedido en el resto de países
del mundo observemos
en nuestra lengua materna líderes de
estados gobierno
es un honor abrir esta asamblea junto a
una represa representante relaciones
soberanas en un punto donde el mundo
necesita
verdad para superar el reto el cabello
sin ave se ha convertido en el centro de
atención de este año y primero quiero
expresar mi sentimiento de pesar por
todas las vidas perdidas desde el
comienzo en mi país advertí que teníamos
dos problemas para resolver el virus y
el desempleo y que ambos problemas
debían ser tratados de manera simultánea
con el mismo sentido de responsabilidad
como se determinó en brasil todas las
medidas sobre estos aumentos sociales
restricciones de movimiento fueron
delegadas a cada uno de los 27
gobernadores de la federación el
presidente en turno fue asignado para
res como
repartir los recursos a nivel nacional
segmentos de la de los medios en brasil
ha politizado el virus esparciendo el
miedo
diciendo que deben quedarse de casa y
nos oponemos luego de la economía pero
nuestra a mi nación en un paso
arriesgado
por ejemplo la ayuda de emergencia se
dio a mí me dólares a 65 millones de
personas el programa más grande para las
personas pobres en brasil y quizás en el
mundo
para ayudar a las empresas pequeñas
más de 200.000 familias indígenas fueron
ayudadas con alimentos y con esfuerzos
de prevención
en cuanto a trabajo con las personas de
la salud 400 millones de dólares se han
invertido en el desarrollo de la vacuna
de oxford en brasil
los hospitales han tenido la capacidad
para tratar a los pacientes de kobe la
pandemia nos enseña una
de visión mayor que no podemos depender
de unas pocas naciones en cuanto a la
producción para nuestra supervivencia él
hidroxi la hidroxi cloroquina
ha aumentado el 500 por ciento desde el
inicio de esta pandemia pero así nos ha
aumentado
la tecnología industria 4.0 de la
inteligencia artificial la
nanotecnología y la tecnología 5g con
todos nuestros socios que respetan
nuestra soberanía y que valoran la
libertad y la protección de datos en
brasil a pesar de la crisis mundial la
producción agricultor nunca se detuvo
agricultores han trabajado como nunca
haya producido los alimentos para
alimentar a más de un billón de personas
brasil
ha continuado alimentando al mundo
nuestros conductores de aviación han
mantenido las logísticas activas para
mantener la producción
y sobre todo
protege la legislación ambiental del
planeta somos víctimas de una campaña de
desinformación acerca de las amazonas
lava son yo brasileña es conocida por
ser y mentalmente es rica
eso sí se evidencia con el apoyo
internacional que he recibido
aprovechadoras en patriótica con el
objetivo de proyectar como bien propio
operación
somos líderes cuando en lo que se
refiere a los
bosques tropicales tenemos la mayor
diversidad somos uno de las 10 economías
más grandes del mundo sólo tenemos el 3
por ciento de emisión de carbono en el
mundo entregamos la seguridad
alimentaria a un sexto de la población
mundial y esto manteniendo el 66 por
ciento de nuestra vegetación y
utilizando sólo el 27 por ciento de
nuestro territorio para los animales y
la agricultura estas son cifras que
ningún otro país tiene brasil se destaca
por el producto es más grande y por eso
hay tanta interés en emitir información
errada estamos abiertos al mundo para
darle lo mejor de nosotros nuestros
productos agrícolas nunca hemos
deportado exportado tanto que como ahora
el mundo depende de brasil para
alimentarse
nuestro bosque tropical los incendios
ocurren virtualmente en lugares cercanos
al bosque tropical donde las familias
indígenas generan incendios para poder
mantener a sus animales me mantengo por
mi política de 'tolerancia cero' en mi
administración hemos logrado
y quiero recordar que la región amazonas
es más grande que toda la región este de
europa no solo los incendios pero
también
la tala ilegal estamos expandiendo y
mejorando la tecnología impro y
mejorando los esfuerzos de las fuerzas
armadas para proteger estos lugares
y nuestros humedales se encuentran ante
los mismos problemas los incendios son
consecuencias de las grandes temperatura
de las altas temperaturas
nuestra preocupación para el medio
ambiente va más allá de nuestros bosques
nuestro programa
nacional uno de los primeros en ser
lanzados a nivel nacional ha diseñado
estrategias para nuestra costa que cubre
8 mil 500 kilómetros
brasil es otro esfuerzo en el 25 en
madrid para establecer bajo las
previsiones de la puerta de parís
un mercado efectivo internacional de
carbón en 2019 brasil fue víctima
de un derrame d
y petróleo por parte de venezuela y que
causó una catástrofe en el mar de brasil
afectando al mercado de
de acuerdo con las reglas de protección
y medioambiente deben ser respetadas y
los actos criminales deben ser
investigados para asegurar que las
ofensas aquellas contra brasil no pueden
ser aceptadas para otros usuarios por
otros países
brasil defiende la protección del medio
ambiente pero también los derechos
humanos en un área donde brasil es ahora
ejemplo en la región apoyando a los
refugiados venezolanos
que han llegado a la región de roraima
quieras o reciba más de 400 mil
venezolanos desplazados como un
resultado de la crisis política y
económica
liderada por la dictadura venezuela más
de cuatro mil brasileños miembros del
ejército han participado las labores
logísticas y humanitarias para la
bienvenida a los refugiados que llegan a
las fronteras brasil se compromete a los
principios básicos de la onu paz y
seguridad internacional cooperación
entre naciones el respeto por los
derechos humanos y las libertades
fundamentales mientras la organización
celebra el aniversario 75 tenemos la
oportunidad de renovar ese compromiso y
la lealtad la lealtad a estos
compromisos la paz no se puede asociar
de la seguridad la cooperación entre las
personas no puede ser es asociada de la
libertad brasil
inscrito en su propio show y
tradicionalmente ha contribuido para
tras traducir estos principios a la
realidad brasil aparte y sino más de
operaciones para mantenerle en paz más
de 50 procesos y ha contribuido con más
de 55 mil personas de la autoridad en
angola en timor haití el canal de suez
el líbano y en el congo
dos militares mujeres fueron reconocidas
en naciones unidas por su trabajo contra
la violencia sexual
firmado dentro
hemos participado del acuerdo firmado
entre la mercosur y la unión europea
estos acuerdos contienen previsiones
importantes para reforzar nuestra
protección a la protección del medio
ambiente y ahora adoptado la liberación
como una clave para crecer y el
desarrollo y transformación reafirma el
compromiso
que nos debe mantener con las
disciplinas con las nuevas realidades
internacionales nos estamos acercando a
un proceso oficial para la acción de
brasil a la ucedé para ello tenemos la
regulación financiera la seguridad
digital y la protección del medio
ambiente en mi primer año en el gobierno
hemos logrado con éxito la reforma
pensional y hemos emitido dos proyectos
al congreso para incluir un sistema de
impuestos y la reforma de la ministra y
administrativa del estado
y regulación en gas natural y de sanidad
esto va a traer mayores inversiones
proveer mayores estímulos económicos
crear economía
en el 2019
brasil era el cuarto país con mayor
inversión en el mundo pero a pesar de la
pandemia hemos visto el aumento en la
inversión este año con respecto al año
pasado esto muestra la confianza a
nuestro gobierno en coordinación
brasil ha mostrado para
y reforzar
en américa latina'
continuaremos
para promover la democracia la
democracia como una pieza clave del
progreso de la economía que todos
deseamos la libertad
es uno de los derechos y características
más grandes que tiene la humanidad
debemos luchar contra la cristofobia
quiero expresar mi solidaridad y mi
apoyo a las personas del líbano en
cuanto a lo que han vivido recientemente
es momento de ver horizontes más
optimistas para el futuro del medio
oriente los acuerdos de paz entre israel
y los emiratos árabes unidos entre
israel y bahrein tres países amigos de
brasil que nuestro gobierno ha mantenido
unas buenas relaciones son noticias
excelentes brasil da la bienvenida al
plan de paz y prosperidad lanzado por el
presidente de donald trump que establece
una visión prometedora para retomar un
mejor camino para solucionar el
conflicto israelí-palestino después de
más de siete décadas de esfuerzos la
nueva política brasil de perseguir
las relaciones de israel y las naciones
árabes está alineado con estas
iniciativas que finalmente muestran una
luz de esperanza a esta región brasil es
un país cristiano y conservador
y la fundación es la familia gracias
muchas gracias